une place de camping ou un hôtel au mois
de juillet ou au mois d'août
je crains qu'il ne soit pas raisonnable
jeudi je crains qu'ils ne soient pas
raisonnable d'imaginer
[Musique]
salut comme à chaque fois qu'il se passe
un truc à la télévision en ce moment
vous me demander d'en faire l'analyse je
ne le fais pas systématiquement et tout
à l'heure je reviendrai dessus pour vous
dire pourquoi mais aujourd'hui on va
faire l'analyse de l'espèce de
conférence de presse qui avait signé
hier par edouard philippe et plusieurs
intervenants dont olivier ferrand
d'autres ministres ou des intervenants
simplement extérieur cette analyse sera
un mélange de verbal de non verbale et
de parra verbal voilà comme ça j'ai bien
tout couvert et je peux dire à peu près
tout ce que j'ai envie de dire je vais
être comme à chaque fois le plus
impartiale possible et comme d'habitude
petit disclaimer regarder le surtout si
c'est la première fois que vous voyez
l'une de mes vidéos
je m'appelle fabien olicard je suis
passionné par le mental par les sciences
et par extension aussi par le mentalisme
depuis toujours et quand je fais ces
analyses la non verbale et bien ou para
verbal d'ailleurs j'utilise des
techniques de psychologie des choses que
je vais piocher dans la pnl qui est
considéré aujourd'hui comme une pseudo
science et je sais que souvent dans les
commentaires me dis bah non c'est pas
vrai et bien si c'est vrai alors que ça
m'empêche pas d'avoir fait des études
mais aussi là dedans même parfois même
dans la synergologie ce qui est encore
pire d'ailleurs que la pnl donc ça aussi
c'est une pseudo science mais ça
n'empêche que je prends quand même des
outils pour regarder un petit peu ce qui
se passe là dedans
donc ça veut dire que mon analyse elle
est très personnelle elle n'engage que
moi elle ne fait pas preuve de vérité
scientifique surtout loin de là et ne la
prenez surtout pas comme tel prenez là
comme un avis peu éclairé mais
complètement subjectif et du coup si
vous n'êtes pas prêt à ça avec ce disque
les moeurs ne regardez pas la vidéo nous
vous fait pas du mal pour rien et alain
vert si vous voulez un jour parler de
moi ou de mes analyses et bien rappeler
quand même que je fais ce 10 km heure
avant ce serait quand même beaucoup plus
honnête quand vous faites des vidéos sur
fabien olicard et le non verbal qui
n'existe pas merci beaucoup
la question récurrente juste avant de
commencer c'est pourquoi je ne fais pas
les analyses systématiques des
allocutions du président mâcon belle
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
j'ai jamais dit que je ferais des
analyses systématiques des allocutions
présidentielles
la dernière que j'avais fait juste avant
donc celle sur le comique 19 c'était
celle des gilet jaune qui remonte à plus
d'un an et demi et la deuxième chose
c'est que je fais une analyse quand j'ai
quelque chose à dire quand j'ai envie de
le faire et puis je ne veux pas que
cette chaîne deviennent aussi forcément
une chaîne politique et que oui ça
ferait sûrement beaucoup de vues sur la
chaîne et ce serait très très cool mais
ce serait un peu facile de faire ça
alors c'est parti anna misons monsieur
edouard philippe
et monsieur olivier ferrand
parce que ce qui m'intéresse le plus on
va pas évidemment faire les deux heures
dix ça n'a pas tellement d'intérêt l'âge
moi je les regardais en direct donc là
pour une fois j'ai tout vu ce qu'était
vraiment intéressant c'était plutôt la
dernière partie quand ils font la
conférence de presse donc et or philippe
et olivier ferrand parce que il ya deux
heures qui sont passés parce qu'il ya
une certaine fatigue et surtout un vrai
lâcher prise de la part de ces deux
intervenants et c'est là où je me dis il
ya peut-être des choses à voir et à
creuser
il ya trois semaines avec le ministre
des solidarités de la santé olivier
ferrand j'avais tenu à organiser une
conférence de presse
ici dans les bureaux du premier ministre
à matignon pour expliquer le plus
complètement possible le plus clairement
possible
quel était notre stratégie face à
l'épidémie de kobe 19 pour vous dire ce
que nous savions et ce que nous ne
savions pas là je vous ai laissé le tout
début on est clairement au tout début de
l'allocution d'edouard philippe et ce
qui est intéressant de regarder c'est
par rapport à ces expressions ces
mouvements de sourcils les mouvements de
son corps il se positionne liste des
positionne on est sur quelque chose
d'assez naturel en fait quelqu'un qui
vient faire un discours qui un peu
stressé mais raisonnablement mais on
voit aussi une certaine posture c'est
normal c'est le tout début je les
laissais là pour que vous puissiez voir
le contraste avec la fin quand la
fatigue a pris le dessus et qui va être
dans le relâchement on va dire pas le
plus complet mais plus intéressant
nous passons directement à 1h 46 du
discours c'est à dire le moment où ils
ont fini de faire toutes leurs séances
d'information et de ré cap et on va
passer aux questions réponses
journalistique ou en fait je crois si
j'ai bien compris que c'est une personne
qui cumule toutes les questions qu
envoie les agences de presse pour les
retranscrire au premier ministre et au
ministre des solidarités de la santé
présentation un peu longue mais il ya
des questions nous y répondons aussi
longtemps que vous souhaiterez nous en
poser j'avais cru voir quelque chose
mais non rien de spécial c'est ça c'est
comme quoi faut pas tout interpréter là
on est sur un visage en fait vraiment
conclusif et d'attentes dire qu'il vient
de terminer sa partie il regarde ses
notes ou est-ce qu'on en est et surtout
il a dit quelque chose d'intéressant
c'est on va répondre aux questions aussi
longtemps que vous aurez à nous imposer
donc en gros
il y a
environ 20 minutes de questions-réponses
et c'est ça qu'on va analyser on a bien
compris que vous travaillez encore sur
cette organisation de déconfinement
est-ce qu'il ya d'ores et déjà des
scénarios de déconfinement que vous
excluez vous parliez par exemple des
personnes de plus de 65 ans donc c'est
très intéressant à regarder ils ont
exactement la même expression sur le
visage et c'est ça qui est intéressant
quand on fait de la double analyse en
même temps comme on a pu faire avec moi
que c'est zemmour si vous n'avez pas vu
la vidéo
c'est la dernière analyse je crois qui
est sorti donc on a le visage qui est
qui ressemblerait à de la colère si on
regarde dessus les sourcils mais en fait
les yeux par contre ne sont pas
écarquillés les narines non plus et
surtout on a la bouche qui est
complètement droite et cas pas du tout
légèrement entrouverte au contraire
aller serrer donc on est sur une vraie
concentration une vraie implication sans
jugement en fait sans position de valeur
sur la personne ou la question qui est
posée mais salaires qui sont vraiment
par contre au taquet paiement par
tranche d'âge mais par région par métier
peut-être et autre question qu'est ce
qui ferait que la date du 11 mai ne
puisse pas être tenus je crois que nous
avons répondu d'une certaine façon au
caractère progressif les cafés les
restaurants n'ont pas là et là par
rapport au tout début de l'allocution
souvenez-vous les premières images sais
pas si loïc vous en remettra une juste
pour comparer mais la position qu'il
tient ici c'est à dire qu'au départ on
l'avait vraiment comme ça ou comme ça
c'est à dire ça c'est une position de
soutien mais avait quand même magistrale
et une position d'euros fermement aux
d'explications aussi relativement à un
magistral là on est vraiment sûr de la
discussion
au sens littéral du terme on n'est pas
sûr sera sur quelqu'un qui cherche à se
maîtriser à ce moment là et c'est ça
dont je vous parlais le relâchement
qu'ils ont à la fin de cette
présentation et qui m'intéressent mettra
en oeuvre de façon différenciée la
doctrine que nous installons parce que
parce que la situation n'est pas la même
sur l'ensemble du territoire parce que
les possibilités parce que les menaces
ne sont pas les mêmes donc c'est quelque
chose de très progressif c'est quelque
chose de différencier c'est un très
grand travail qui est en train d'être là
on a eu vraiment une expression qui
était sympa j'essaie de la retrouver
voilà celle ci celle ci elle est
parfaite toujours dans l'analyse il ya
une forme de neutralité qui est très
intéressante c'est pas de m'excuser
c'est pas de la colère c'est pas de la
tristesse c'est pas de la déception je
trouve que c'est la première fois qu'on
trouve cette forme de sincérité tout à
fait pur dans ses discours là avec le
visage pensiez le regarde passer vers le
loin les sourcils légèrement levé qui
est du fatalisme mais pas négatif qui et
c'est comme ça on n'en sait pas plus et
on va faire ce qu'il a à faire vous
pouvez reconnaître cette expression à
cette gestuelle
quand quelqu'un vous dit qu'est ce que
tu veux que j'y fasse en fait on l'a
exactement ici et je trouve ça
intéressant parce que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui les discours présidentiels
que j'avais vu il disait pas tout et son
contraire mais il était trop trop enrobé
lassé de la première fois que je vois
aussi un côté de on fait au mieux
donc c'est exactement ce qu'on a ici
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise et on n'a pas de re d'autres choix
de le faire comme ça c'est hyper
intéressant de voir qu'il n'ya pas
d'émotion particulière qui est collée
dessus cause de différencier c'est un
très grand travail qui est en train
d'être et on a toujours le seul
mouvement de sourcils à chaque fois
réalisé et encore une fois il ne peut
être réalisé complètement qu'en bonne
intelligence avec les autres partenaires
de l'état et les haussements d'épaulés
que j'essaie de décrire et que je
remercie de leur réserve
au moment où je le fais les mains se
relève d' art qu'est ce que tu veux que
je fasse j'ai pas le pouvoir absolu dans
les mains c'est exactement ça que ça
veut dire et le pouvoir absolu et ce
n'est pas sans pouvoir politique à ce
moment là c'est le pouvoir face au co
vite 19
je relis cette question est tout de même
à une confrères des échos qui vous
interroge sur les données dont vous
disposez aujourd'hui les projections
chiffrées est ce qu on sait à peu près
combien de français pourraient être
hospitalisé à ce moment là une petite
pause juste aussi pour pour le principe
la position dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure on a exactement la même part
olivier véran ça veut dire qu'il va être
dans le même état d'esprit que le
premier ministre sur sur la suite et sur
sa manière d'aborder le sujet
entrée en service de réanimation les
projections sur le nombre de cas de
nouvelle infection estimée à l'horizon
du 11 mai à chaque fois qui dit qui
parle de 11 mais là c'est la deuxième
fois qu'on en entend parler il y avait
au tout début aussi
il avait d'ailleurs coller le 11 mai au
président dans sa responsabilisation
c'est à dire que la date du 11 mai fixée
par le président de la république il y
avait un sous-entendu de cette date là
lui appartient et elle nous a été
imposée et on travaille dessus pour
qu'elle soit possible et là à chaque
fois qu'ils dénonceraient on a quand
même un petit changement de visage avec
un voile à la on à l'ouverture de la
bouche et c'est un recul on le voit
clairement juste leur met peut-être un
tout petit peu plus fluide
donc là il va le prononcé vous voyez
déjà ça bug un petit peu avant de le
dire avant de parler du 11 mai
le changement de visage et le recul du
corps du 11 mai tu joues et après on
baisse les yeux
je pense à ces sincèrement c'est mon
analyse encore une fois les subjectif
elle fait parfois de vérité que cette
date là c'est un problème pour lui non
pas que ce soit le 11 mai au 12 mois ou
le 10 mai mais le fait d'avoir voulu
absolument donner une date d'espoir très
franc que les personnes peuvent sur
interprétée comme si le déconfinement
points c'est pas quelque chose qui est
arrangeant pour lui qui est au coeur de
la matrice en train de régler les choses
avec beaucoup d'inconnues encore
aujourd'hui donc il ya une espèce de
forme de roger de cette date là je crois
qu'il aimerait pouvoir en faire le déni
est comme une petite forme de déni
dessus est ce qu'il ya des cas en france
de malades guéris ayant été testés
positifs ultérieurement et si oui
combien et combien de temps après je
parle sous le contrôle du directeur
général de la sem marc olivier veyrat là
il a eu alors on sait qu'il est dans le
relâchement les tout à l'heure il y a de
plus en plus de questions autour de
cette immunité que confère ou non les
anticorps ça fait partie des
incertitudes vous disiez d'ailleurs
professeur a l'air tout à l'heure
est ce qu'il ya des cas en france de
malades guéris ayant été testés positifs
du térieur mans et si oui combien et
combien de temps à bagdad lave je parle
sous le contrôle du directeur général de
la santé qui indique qu' il n'y a pas de
cas en france tels que ce que vous
décrivez
comment ça va être en officine est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir distribuer ces
masques est ce qu'ils seront payants
est-ce qu'il faudra des ordonnances
alors c'est un des sujets compliqués
c'est pas le sol mais c'est un des
sujets compliqués du plan de
déconfinement tous ces mouvements de
mains et le fait de reprendre cette
position c'est pas forcément tant dans
le lied aussi que pour trouver un appui
l'un à ce moment précis de la vidéo et
on voit avec un peu de stress de frotter
la main je pense pas que c'est du stress
de je ne sais pas quoi répondre c'est du
stress de on a encore besoin de temps en
fait pour mettre tout ça en place et en
a conscience de la problématique assez
honnête mais ce sont les masques
chirurgicaux est une question qui est
délicate parce que vous le savez on a
fait une réquisition c'est à dire qu'on
a dit on contrôle désormais toutes les
capacités de distribution de ces masques
pour être sûr que tous les matchs 8
c'est très intéressant parce que tout ce
qu'on vient de voir là les quelques
secondes ou olivier père en parler il a
à peu près ces attitudes là c'est à dire
l'engagement total donc il est toujours
très concentré on le voit au niveau des
sourds si on le voit à les cartes
iman des yeux et sûrement si on était un
peu plus près on le verrait aussi à la
contraction ou la dilatation de la
pupille
mais on est on est on est quelqu'un qui
fait partie absolument du game comme
s'il était soldat et qu'il avait une
mission et c'est intéressant dans ses
intonations pas ce que ça veut dire
qu'on peut prendre à priori pour argent
comptant ce qu'il va dire en tout cas ça
veut dire que lui croit vraiment à ce
qu'il dit est ce qui fait à ce moment là
donc c'est hyper intéressant pour être
sûr que tous les masques utile aille aux
soignants qui en ont vraiment besoin
vous voyez là tout ce qui a eu avec la
déglutition l'acquiescement de la tête
des bleus en même temps et c'est juste
avant de reprendre c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut pas simuler on peut pas
placer sabots long terme en à la fin
d'une phrase c'est une sorte d'auto
acquiescement en fait il vient de faire
avec des masques que les pharmacies
auraient acheté de leur côté pour
pouvoir les vendre donc on est en train
de regarder ça change
avec la présidente de l'ordre des
pharmaciens qui j'ai promis d'ailleurs
un appel avant demain matin vous le
rappeler afin de trouver le bon moyen de
faire mais encore une fois si les
pharmacies ça c'est rigolo vous c'est
dans la détection du mensonge de la
vérité on sait que abreuver un discours
de détails inutiles
c'est un signe de vérité est là c'est un
peu rigolo on l'a même plus sourire
juste par rapport à ça quand il a dit il
faut que je le rappelle le demain matin
donc c'est bien de me faire penser c'est
une piste de vérité absolue ça d'ici la
mi mai mais on l'a non seulement vous
l'annoncer seulement maintenant reuters
attendait pardon oui voilà reuters
france télévision s'interroge donc
pourquoi la france n'a pas tel le voir
le tous les signaux de fatigue ils sont
là c'est pour ça qu'on arrive à avoir
quelque chose d'assez sincère du coup ça
fait moins de choses à dire dans
l'analyse mais l'analyse elle-même de
quelque chose de sincère et intéressante
réussi n'at-elle pas réussi avant
accroître sa capacité de dépistage plus
rapidement comme ça a été le cas en
allemagne est ce que c'est à cause d'un
manque de kit est ce qu on appelle le
pape lui l'allemagne il s'est relevé
olivier ferrand il s'est relevé il
circule un petit peu il a redressé le
menton la comparaison avec l'allemagne
ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'il y à peu
qu'il y avait plus parce qu'on a tardé à
développer ces tests et le monde ajoute
que vous ne faites pas le choix de
tester les personnes asymptomatiques au
moment du des confirmands est ce que l
c'est là aussi dû là c'est vraiment
l'image de hockey alors ça ça fait
partie des choses qui m'agacent et
olivier ferrand qui dit est ce que c'est
moi qui va avoir la parole ou pas parce
qu'on a vus par le tout les petits
signes de mouvement et de début de
réponse juste non verbale voire verbal
qu'il était en train de formuler pendant
qu'elle posait la question qu'il a des
choses bien une incapacité une capacité
on a le mouvement du corps qui a fait ça
donc je crois qu'il va passer la parole
des testings insuffisante en france
et voilà je passe ne serait ce que par
son regard monsieur le ministre
très rapidement encore une fois où cette
personne vit avec nous a été en contact
rapproché avec quelqu'un qui a de la
fièvre et des symptômes
là il faut être capable de tester parce
que là c'est utile aucun pays au monde
n'est pas croire aucun pays au monde ne
procède à un dépistage systématique d
assab thématique ça n'existe pas si vous
regardez les écarts prenez vous avez
cité l'allemagne l'allemagne était aux
dernières nouvelles plutôt aux alentours
de 55 mille à 60 mille tests jours donc
elle est très très loin du dépistage est
symptomatique faut bien que vous
comprenez quelque chose au stade 1 quand
le virus n'était pas vraiment encore
rentré alors juste avant la partie
démonstrative louis-ii oui parle du
stade 1 je vais pas revenir dessus parce
que s'il n'y a pas une image précise mme
on a tous les signaux corporels de micro
expressions de visage de tout l'ensemble
qui démontre ce que je disais tout à
l'heure une espèce d'engagement alors je
ne suis pas là pour préjuger de la
qualité de ce qu'il dit et des solutions
qui l'amène je ne sais pas du tout
compétent dessus et c'est pas ce que je
fais mais en tout cas lui croit beaucoup
au bien fondé de ce qu'il raconte
comme quoi c'est la bonne décision et
que c'est le bon combat qu'il en train
de mener
et c'est ça moi que je peux voir et
retransmettre et qui est intéressant au
mouvement on va lever le confinement il
sera indispensable de recommencer avec
ce que nous avons fait auparavant en
réalité qui de dépister toutes personnes
susceptibles d'être malade et toute
personne contact du alors que veut dire
ce petit nom qu'on a eu deux fois quand
il dit on on va recommencer à faire ce
qu'on faisait avant je vous remet juste
la petite négation pas de recommencer
avec ce que nous avons fait auparavant
en réalité qui de dépister toutes
personnes susceptibles en fait le seul
nom n'est pas imputable à ce qu'il est
en train de dire l'a déjà sinon ce
serait pas un double non ça veut dire
que sa pensée la tante aller relatives à
la question qui était posée 2
ils apparaissent qu'il faudrait tester
les asymptomatiques en fait lui à ce
moment là quand il dit on va refaire
comme on a fait avancer non on ne va pas
testé en son nom répond à la question en
réalité plus de tests qu'aucune personne
susceptible d'être malade ne soit privé
d'un test il n'y a pas eu de
l'atermoiement il n'y a pas eu
d'attentât
c'est compliqué pour tous les pays du
monde je vais vous dire je m'entretiens
au quotidien avec 100 g la lazio de rome
a également regardé la position qu'il a
ici ils étaient encore démonstrative
parce qu'il avait besoin de faire de la
pédagogie sur le sujet qu'il était en
train d'aborder et un moment donné vous
allez voir la décrochent mentalement et
physiquement sur quelque chose qui va
revenir la conversation très sincère
parce que nous soyons que ces records
l'usure dépistage est donc plus de tests
qu'aucune personne susceptible d'être
malade ne soit privé d'un test il n'y a
pas eu d'autres termes allemand il n'y a
pas eu d'attentât si compliqué à plat il
n'y a pas eu d'appel à un moment il n'y
a pas eu de et en fait ça tous relâchés
et en fait c'est compliqué on peut
comparer les places de réa peut comparer
les noms de médicaments dont comparer
qui fait quoi avec les masques moi je
vous dis juste que je suis fier de mon
système de santé français pierre de
l'hôpital de france est fière des
réanimations firent de ces soignants etc
ont fait le maximum pour les protéger et
nous préparer pour protéger les français
voilà ça revient à l'image que je vous
ai dit tout départ de l'analyse sur sur
libérant quand encore il était en mode
combattants c'est ça c'est combattants
mais général donc là en fait ils ses
troupes lui tiennent à coeur
une place de camping ou un hôtel au mois
de juillet ou au mois d'août en france
ou à l'étranger
je crains qu'il ne soit pas raisonnable
jeudi je crains qu'il ne soit pas
raisonnable d'imaginer voilà ce
mouvement des mains vous vous
reconnaissez vous le reconnaissez ins et
c'est pas de ma faute
on ne tape pas terrasse et je suis que
le messager et je crois je crains qu'il
n'est pas raisonnable d'espérer des
choses sûres à 100% pour la suite ok eh
bien écoutez c'était très intéressant
c'était une analyse d'un autre genre
encore une fois je n'avais pas voulu
faire les deux dernières des manuels
macron parce que il ya il ya un côté
trop protecteur trop confuse en fait de
la manière de parler certains discours
présidentiel assez classique trop
préparé trop écrit je trouve que là on
avait une vraie présentation de l'action
une vraie présentation et des vrais
discours de mecs sur le terrain j'ai pas
trop vu le premier ministre edouard
philippe et le ministre olivier ferrand
j'ai plus vu de mecs qui triment et qui
venaient partager leurs expériences de
ça de tout ce que j'ai vu sur le colis
de 19
c'est moi en tant que citoyen la chose
que je viens de préférer voir avec mon
regard un peu d'analysé
parce que parce que j'ai des grandes
réponses dedans avec de la sincérité
derrière ils compris dans tous les
endroits où sa vie on sait pas en fait
et si je crois que c'était aussi
important que nous transmettent les
choses où ils savent et ils savent pas
alors attention parce que là je vous
connais quand sur des politiciens je
suis pas cool avec eux dans l'analyse
peuvent pas ce que je dis juste ce que
je vois vous dite anéantie lui était
anti lui et quand sur ces mêmes
politiciens jeudi à b tient là c'était
sincère et honnête j'ai dû habiter
produite et invendus et où je suis ni
l'un ni l'autre en fait je m'en fous
complètement de la vie politique il
s'est juste impartiale et je dis
honnêtement alors c'est vrai que des
fois je critique et des fois la liesse
était pas tellement de la critique
c'était de l'analyse de hockey on est
sur du relâchement de l'honnêteté et où
après l'intérieur de ce qu'ils lisent
peut plaire ou ne pas plaire ce assez
à vous de voir voilà c'était important
de le préciser pour la fin si cette
vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à liker
si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné cette
chaîne youtube je m'appelle fabien
olicard abonnez vous et regardez un
petit peu ce que je fais ça peut vous
intéresser active la cloche c'est
important pour voir les sorties de
nouvelles vidéos
et si vous ne saviez pas j'ai dit
également un magazine papier qui
s'appelle curieuse qui sort tous les
mois il n'est disponible que sur
abonnement pour un an
ça représente un peu moins de 2 euros 50
par mois et là exceptionnellement vous
avez accès aussi en ce moment en version
pdf du magazine avec les problèmes
d'impression d'envoi et de courtage il
ya pour des problèmes que nous
connaissons bien en ce moment
prenez très simple vous restez chez vous
à très bientôt ciao